On February 10th, the US House Judiciary
Subcommittee on the Constitution and
Limited Government held a high-profile
hearing titled Sharia Free America: Why
Political Islam and Sharia law are
incompatible with the US Constitution?
That's all well and good, but it does
also beg the question, what exactly is
the difference between Islam on the one
hand and political Islam and Sharia law
on the other? I ask because it seems
that a great many Western people are
suffering from what's known as the
distinction without a difference
fallacy. Consider these two positions
which many in the West would seem to
embrace. One, freedom of religion is a
cornerstone of the western way of life.
Therefore, Muslims and Islam are welcome
in the West. Two, Sharia law is
antithetical to the Western way of life.
Therefore, Sharia has no place in the
West. Many Americans would, for example,
say something like this. I am a firm
believer in freedom of religion. As
such, I find it unconscionable to
prevent Muslims from coming, living, and
freely practicing their faith in
America. That said, I'm an avowed foe of
Sharia, which absolutely has no place in
America. There are many examples of
people speaking and thinking this way
straight to the top, beginning with the
American president himself. For example,
Donald J. Trump has made many welcoming
and inclusive gestures to Muslims in
America. Last Ramadan, he issued the
following greeting. Quote, "As millions
of Muslim Americans begin their Ramadan
observances, my administration
recommmits to upholding religious
liberty that is such an integral part of
the American way of life. This Ramadan,
I offer my best wishes. May God bless
you and your families during this
wondrous season." But Trump has also
said, quote, "Anyone who believes Sharia
law supplants American law will not be
given an immigrant visa. If you want to
join our society, then you must embrace
our society, our values, and our
tolerant way of life." So, on the one
hand, Trump respects and honors the
religious liberty of millions of Muslim
Americans during the wondrous season of
Ramadan. On the other hand, he firmly
rejects Sharia law for being
antithetical to quote our American
society, our values, and our tolerant
way of life. Now, this contrarian way of
thinking exemplifies the distinction
without a difference fallacy that many,
if not most, Americans commit concerning
Islam. They seem to think that a major
difference exists between being a Muslim
and being an inherent of Sharia, being a
Muslim and being a follower of political
Islam. Hence why only a few Americans,
especially their politicians, are
willing to criticize Islam while a great
many have no problem criticizing Sharia.
Reality of course is much different.
Simply put, Islam is the descriptive
name of the religion. Sharia is the
prescriptive way of upholding it. They
are inseparable. To be a Muslim is by
definition to be one who adheres to
Sharia. This is even evident in the
etmology of the words themselves. Islam
means submission or surrender. And a
Muslim is one who has submitted or
surrendered. Submitted or surrendered to
what exactly? Well, to Allah's will. And
how does one go about ascertaining
Allah's will? Well, through his revealed
book, the Quran, and through the words
and deeds of Allah's prophet, Muhammad,
who was sent to be an excellent example
for humanity to follow, according to
Quran 33:21, taken together, the many
commandments and prohibitions derived
from the Quran from and from Muhammad's
example or Sunnah show Muslims the way
to live, indeed, the way to life, which
is the literal definition of Sharia. In
the classical Arabic of Muhammad's time,
Sharia meant the path or roadway to
water. Considering the desiccated and
arid conditions of Arabia, the path to
water was synonymous with the path to
life. Hence why that word was chosen to
describe Islamic law. Sharia then is not
just how Muslims should live. It is the
way to life itself. In this sense,
Sharia is not so dissimilar from how
early Christian texts such as the
dedicos
in Greek. Here at last we come to the
root problem. The Muslim way of life is
in many respects antithetical to the
western way of life. Not least as the
latter was at least in its origins based
on the Christian way of life. Think
about it. Hate for discrimination
against and jihad on non-Muslims,
wife beating, polygamy, even sex
slavery, draconian punishments for
including execution of those who
blaspheme against Muhammad or try to
apostatize from Islam. All of these are
part of Sharia. That is all of these are
part of the Muslim way of and to life.
No less than Islam's so-called five
pillars, prayer, fasting, etc. In short,
to be a practicing Muslim is to be a
Sharia compliant Muslim. They are one
and the same. Now, if we turn to ongoing
developments in Texas, which is what
prompted the recent House hearing on
Sharia, it's clear that Americans are
increasingly becoming aware that Sharia,
the Muslim way, directly contradicts the
Western way. And they have no problem
calling it as they see it. As in the
recent House hearing, which has the word
Sharia in it. Too many of them, however,
still speak as if Sharia is some
unnecessary accretion to Islam,
something ignored by most Muslims, an
option, something that's practiced only
by those pesky radicals. If they
understood just how inextricable Islam
and Sharia are, when they say things
like, "Sharia law is not allowed in
Texas," as Greg Abbott, the governor of
that state, regularly affirms, they
would understand that what they are
really saying is that Islam itself is
not allowed in the West. Bring back the
fight.
Bring back the flame.
Bring back the fire and the rightous
name.